the last thing I have not mentioned in
the back told me versus t-series my
final move I have revealed all my
strengths so far extremely handsome and
good-looking very big tongue
I can eat G fuel raw crab king but
number 5 listen to this I am incredibly
slow 140 IQ 200 Eiko I don't make me
laugh ha 5000 IQ is that all you have my
IQ has been measured to 100 million
hundred so don't even try and compete
with me because I am just too smart
thank you now of course we're going to
review I am very smart of course because
you are very smart and you knew this was
coming
let's review and look at other very
smart people to intimidate T series on
earth a magician puts his hand on his in
his hat in the rabbit round the hand
emerges it is time the rabbit council
must choose a sacrifice actually that's
not what's happening magicians use these
techniques such as to misdirection and
prestige it dictation to pull up these
illusions yes I know I am a nerdy this
has to be sarcastic I know magic isn't
real I'm in quite a nerd yeah not
everyone will get this this is a really
tricky meme that not everyone will get
those alcohol molecules and it's @y oh
yeah I forgot you are studying art how
could you possibly know basic level dude
everyone knows as H 1 H 2 O is we were
in the same biology contest last year
and you got fourth place then you got
butthurt and stormed off crying
I am very smart I got hired range in
biology and math than you or did you
forget
oh no I remember I remember walking the
classroom during the lunch break and
hearing and seeing you begging the
teacher for the great because you needed
for college damn someone heard this man
someone hurt this man not everyone would
get he just wanted to share a meme
anyone who doesn't like a big bang it's
just too stupid to get the jokes get it
bang ha ha ha ha oh he posted this that
is just pathetic this song has somewhat
of a 90s vibe that's actually a common
misconception the paradigm inherent to
the post modernist fallacy of a priori
knowledge stems from a systematic
predilection to binary diatom I imagine
anyone being like this in real life you
know they spent a lot of time writing
this down making sure ok let's now add a
predilection to binary dictum and these
don't die Co Tommy's cuz I have these
pictures were taken just two years apart
hash tag stop Meegan's vegans are eating
all our glass we need them to stop we
need to stop that it's called going to a
different biome it's called a joke lmao
oof got him okay yeah I know but I tend
to be too logical for my own I am so
smart that I'm just too logical so when
I am wrong I am actually not wrong I am
too logical you can't compete with this
power instead of saying mother-fricker
you can just say oh they put half our
generation wouldn't understand yes you
are right the thousand of notes on this
pose prove how ignorant our generation
is only you are intelligent you are the
chosen one only real ancient Greek kids
would understand reblog if you were true
650 BC kid
ancient Greek was 2600 years ago this is
embarrassing
shut up I'm very smart
okay I know I am just too logical for my
own good I'm moving up my bed me in the
morning
cats are actually you know when they
were used to work actually you know you
get worried about the hit by the fattest
smart bomb but I like to call it
actually crepuscular which means they
are also quite nocturnal animals using a
cat to represent you is not a big deal
it's catching if they read that that's
all I hear from you you dumb balls okay
how about this no one giving this I'm on
the size of aliens now now that I've
proven myself
s T f you I am smarter than you how
mathematics surrounds me I see numbers
everywhere what the does that even show
pouch to me it's your dick PI inches
long
you just got ins my only masturbate
mentally my thoughts are so intricate
that they can make me her and I love
that I don't believe in physical
masturbation my mind makes me don't make
me think it oopsie nah he's trying to
hold his brain in as his mind gets blown
to be fair those are fairly trivial
equations although I'm sure impressed if
at the time explain them too blurry I
guess I cannot actually see them this is
how you know someone is truly smart
because when confronted with their
statement they contradict themselves
entirely which is the best way to prove
your point
this is also cringe everyone else said
to 10:30 I guess I'll watch
me at twenty ten thirty sees video about
hyperbolic functions wait what
such a thing damn it now I have to watch
it hashtag if math is your curse then
smash like subscribe on this video only
true math Lords will understand I asked
my cousin if he liked the book I lent
him did you ever end up enjoying
hyperspace I liked it a lot first
disclaimer I don't believe your own
Bullivant election thought to understand
my theory in its absolute form so I
dumped it down what a great way not at
all condescending to speak to someone I
have to write it's so great how this is
real it's annoying when people write in
whatever I don't know how to say that
just take the extra two seconds and
write out is not the same thing as or is
not equal to you similar it Neanderthal
how about writing two instead of using
two you quazy literate quasi literate
ken is a great test if anyone delivers
that one to you there's no recovery
that's how you know you're not just very
smart but very super smart we have two
Wi-Fi channels one is 2.4 gigahertz and
one is 5 gigahertz I really want to name
them who are you and I am you but
stronger technically if you did so it
would be correct the 5 gigahertz channel
is able to support more devices on its
channel due to it having higher
bandwidth that and it's a more modern
implementation into routers I know
that's why I made the job just pointing
out in case you didn't figured you might
learn something clearly I understand how
the frequencies work well enough to come
up with it
just in case you randomly made a joke
and didn't understand your own punchline
I you are welcome I am very smart iboga
bro Kapoor the two highest IQ scores
ever recorded belong to women unusual
you know you know someone just couldn't
handle this considering I've never met a
woman smarter than me well that's a bit
unfair considering I never met a man
smarter than me either
Oh God Jesus Christ how do these people
exist and why there's so many of them
it's beautiful
had to be done you're welcome Elon Musk
bikes for tonight and deletes it had to
save the kids from eternal virginity
Elon Musk a very real statement here we
go hey Elon Musk it's had to be done
not had to be done it's you're welcome
not you're welcome right correct English
hashtag be cautious with your tweets
Jesus in Christ we're gonna have to end
that video there hope you guys enjoyed
smash like and subscribe if you are
bearish tomorrow just so I can know if
you guys are very smart it is not a ploy
to get more likes and subscribers on
this video you're too smart to
understand that anyway brofist now to
burst simulator it's now so relevant
that it's got a brand new minigame
crania drop the crane and get fresh
items only available in the washing
machine like game and you say there's
more of course there is new knowledge
perks new quests and new pics links and
legs guys like